France is withdrawing its ambassador to
Niger and ending all defense cooperation
after weeks of tension with the military
Junta president Emmanuel macron says the
troops will withdraw by the end of the
year niger's military which seized power
in a coup in July has welcomed the move
calling it a step towards sovereignty
al-shazira's Abdul razak has more from
Miami
the decision by French president
Emmanuel macron to pull out his troops
an ambassador from Niger was met by huge
relief and celebration among the
supporters of niger's military yunta
this has been quite visible in the
capital nyame and across the country
people here see this decision as a
positive step by the French government
to the demands they had even before the
coup of July 26th I spoke to many
citizens who said they now believe the
government is on their side which was
the number one Demand by protesters at
the time president Muhammad bazoom was
ousted now people believe the yunta has
heard the demands of not only the masses
but also organizations and agencies in
the country the military leaders have
welcomed macron's decision as the fruit
of niger's people's struggle calling on
their citizens to continue in their
Quest until total Independence and
sovereignty are restored
the French withdrawal from Niger is the
most recent sign of its waning influence
across West Africa in August last year
the last of the French troops stationed
in Mali left they had been there for
nine years to assist in the fight
against armed groups while French
military operations in Burkina Faso
officially ended in February of this
year and earlier this month Niger Mali
and Burkina Faso formed a mutual defense
pact warning against foreign
interference all three nations are under
military leadership after recent coups
let's talk to Emmanuel quezi Anning
director of research at Kofi Annan
International peacekeeping Training
Center you're joining us from Accra
today and it's great to talk to you
again
the the French troops were in Niger to
help fight armed groups what will happen
to that fight once they're gone
well they are they were in Niger to help
supposedly
five armed groups who would potentially
well why why supposedly would they have
a track record of fighting armed groups
in the region why supposedly
not really they have been they have been
a disaster from when President Holland
in Mali said he had despairs
terrorists the end result was that he
spread them all over the sub-region and
also the French track record on the
sub-region is one of disastrous
intervention and not really helping the
countries in which they have been
stationed so this is not going to affect
um the security situation in the gerato
this is a great success for the military
regime in Yemen are you suggesting that
the fight against armed groups in the
region could actually benefit from the
withdrawal of French soldiers
the French presence has not improved the
living standards not the security of any
of the countries in which they have
performed in I think we shouldn't
deceive ourselves
living standards
they are there for counter Insurgency of
course when there is security it also
improves living standards but I think we
shouldn't deceive ourselves these
military cooperation Agreements are not
for the benefits of the recipient States
they are for the benefits of the
Metropolitan or the metropolis and that
is why there's rejoicement in niamey
because the military regime has been
firmed the Ambassador is living and I
think it has sent a clear signal to all
observers of the situation in the Sahel
that if governments are insistent on
what their national interests are they
will get their way with it I think this
is a great day for the Ordinary People
the French soldiers
um because the French soldiers are
leaving but the American soldiers are
staying and they'll continue doing what
they were doing previously your thoughts
on that
well once more this demonstrates
that even our partners
or cut corners and card deals when it's
used their national interests the
Americans learned how to speak a
language that General Cheney and his
team found acceptable they were not
belligerent they appointed a new
Ambassador albatious not presented their
credentials yet but the Americans
understand
the demands of the people on the ground
across the sub-region and they will
tailor their politics and their policies
to ensure that it is accommodating it is
respectful it is consensual dialogic and
that they always find a way to do a
business with the people who are in
power the French have lost out I mean
because Mr macron has demonstrated the
persistent arrogance
in listening to the voices from the
ground okay you know what so we've been
talking about the French let's forget
about the French because they are
effectively history in the region right
as we detail they left Mali they're no
longer in Burkina Faso in any
significant way and they're going to
leave Niger
what about the people of those countries
whether it's Molly Burkina Faso and
Niger those are three countries that are
deeply heavily destabilized by the armed
groups that are operating and that
control parts of their Sovereign
territories are the people in those
countries going to live better and are
they going to get more security
with the governments that are now in
place led by coup leaders
this is a process
this is a process that is going to take
time I am not worried but in over time
is that a yes or no over time
oh there's going to be security over
time
but let's let's also not forget that the
history of this continent has also
demonstrated that there are times when
the metropols have themselves been
deliberate manipulators of insecurity
so what is happening in Burkina Faso in
Mali we cannot refrain
from thinking who are those who are
giving these groups this new age
okay and history will bear us out
that probably it is not just an
innocent expansion of you know uh
violent extremist power but probably the
other
you know forces who seek to undermine
these regimes who are providing New
Logistics who are providing new
intelligence you know so long term
there's going to be stability there's
going to be growth there's going to be
better resilience and communities are
going to grow I have no doubt at all
that what is happening in these
countries are a reflection of the
broader more dangerous geopolitical game
that is being played because these
governments under all conditions must be
made but when people know what is
happening then they will rally around
this government and DJ has shown us
um
Emmanuel quezi Anning director of
research at the Kofi Annan International
peacekeeping Training Center thank you
for joining us today